jordan peels nope or as i like to call
it the word girls used to say when i
asked them out in high school is peel's
third film after us and get out i would
have voted for obama for a third term if
i could in this video we'll be taking a
deep dive into nope it's ufo the film's
most cryptic elements and of course the
ending so come ride with me past a sea
of sky dancers i honestly didn't know
they were called that because here we go
this is o.j haywood no not that oj a
down and out animal wrangler for the
film and television industry it's a
business his father otis senior and
family started decades ago but after his
father's sudden death when a coin struck
him unexpectedly from the sky we learned
the ranch is in dire financial straits
now you may be asking yourself how does
a coin falling from the sky kill a man
in fact mythbusters debunked the can of
penny falling off the empire state
building kill you myth years ago so
whatever shot that penny from the sky
had to have done so with tremendous
force it couldn't have been debris from
an airplane as the government concluded
the government seems to be covering up a
lot of stuff we later learned that the
aerial view from google in this area is
blurred and the massacre at jupiter's
claim is dismissed as a flash flood but
we'll get to that in a bit before otis
senior is tragically killed we get our
first clue as to how this ufo operates
and i know in the film they sometimes
use the word uap but in this video i'll
be using ufo and monster to describe
this thing it can turn off any sort of
electronic device whether it be plugged
in or battery operated this will become
important later on the film picks up six
months after otis senior's death as we
get glimpses of oj's typical day tending
to the horses you can hear the radio in
the background talk about a missing
tourist peel sprinkles these subtle
hints that this place isn't what it
seems throughout the film oj hasn't
processed the trauma of his father's
death and to make matters worse his job
on set is far from glamorous when a set
worker startles one of oj's horses o.j
is fired and the horse is replaced with
a cg one he's part of a dying industry
one his ancestors founded years ago in
fact emerald oj's sister is sure to
mention to everyone during the safety
meeting that the first film ever
recorded was that of a black man on a
horse that was oj and emerald's distant
grandfather and they've been in this
business ever since fun fact this 1878
film was captured by edward muybridge
and the tmz writer will later meet is
named ryder muybridge to make ends meet
ojs had to sell some of his horses to a
local amusement park called jupiter's
claim a park run by beloved child star
ricky jupe park ricky's entire life has
been one of spectacle he was an actor on
kid sheriff a hit tv show pimps out his
family for an upcoming reality show and
has even rented his special memorabilia
room for people to sleep in a room which
holds items from the gordy show a 1990s
sitcom where this star was a chimpanzee
named gordy who suddenly went crazy and
killed multiple people on set this idea
of spectacle is echoed in the bible
quote shown at the beginning of the film
it's from the book of nahum and states i
will pelt you with filth i will treat
you with contempt and make you a
spectacle many of the animals in the
film are treated with contempt from the
horse's dupe sacrifices to feed the ufo
gordy who's exploited for a tv show and
even oj's horse lucky who's treated
poorly by the crew all of this was done
in the name of spectacle from jup's star
lasso experience which i'll get to in a
bit the gordy show or the film set oj
was working on when we see a spectacle
we can't seem to take our eyes off it so
it's somewhat ironic that the ufo
focuses its attacks on those who look at
it emerald and oj have an okay type of
relationship however it's not without
its resentment emerald was promised on
her ninth birthday that she'd get to
train her own horse jean jacket but
their father ended up giving the horse
to oj to train this is why oj later
calls the ufo jean jacket giving emerald
a chance to tame it that's because this
ufo isn't some flying saucer controlled
by aliens it's an organic being an alpha
predator of unknown origin the title
nope some believe is an acronym for not
of planet earth we're not exactly sure
how long this thing has been here but we
can assume at least six months from otis
senior's death even though he's under
financial stress oj doesn't want to sell
the ranch his father changed the
industry and he can't seem to let that
go the ranch is filled with memorabilia
and oj even keeps the coin that killed
his father and mounts it on the wall so
if they're not going to sell the ranch
they need an alternative source of
income and luckily one night oj
discovers that some sort of ufo has been
circling their ranch emerald has the
crazy idea to catch the ufo on camera if
they could get the first legitimate
proof that some sort of extraterrestrial
has visited the planet that's got to be
enough money to save the ranch so they
do what any rational person would do and
set up a bunch of camera equipment
getting it at fry's which is a now
defunct electronics store which actually
had a ufo display at its burbank
location it's here we're introduced to
angel who ends up being their
electronics expert throughout their
crazy journey in order to attract this
ufo emerald steals a decoy horse from
jupiter's claim and their plan works
sort of the ufo sucks up the decoy horse
like some sort of twister but because of
its ability to turn off electronics one
of the two cameras is disabled while the
other is blocked by a praying mantis
covering the lens a praying mantis that
conveniently unblocks himself from view
as soon as the ufo leaves the movie
deals with a lot of supernatural stuff
but is it too far of a stretch to think
that something may be coercing these
animals there are other such strange
incidents like oj's horse ghost breaks
from his pen and runs towards the ufo
then there's this strange shoe that
magically stands completely upright as
if defying gravity during gordy's attack
not to mention gordy goes from brutally
killing several people to fist-bumping
young jupe maybe this is why jupe
survived instead of looking directly at
the spectacle of gordy killing he was
instead looking at this shoe is
something affecting these animals in
ways we cannot comprehend could this be
what oj refers to as a quote bad miracle
though gorty incident was tragic but jup
profited off of it hell some couple paid
him 50k to sleep in his memorabilia room
i also want to bring up this guy he's
seen multiple times throughout the
trailer but in the theatrical version at
least the one that i watched he was
completely cut from the movie he seems
to be somehow associated with the gordy
show this is probably a reflection of
gordy in his glasses during the massacre
he walks towards the violence unscared
as the crowd seen here wearing 90s
clothes walks away from it he's billed
on imdb as nobody if any of you know who
this guy really is i'd love to hear
about it in the comments with their plan
to capture the ufo on tape a bust
emerald tries to get that
cinematographer from the shoot they were
on at the beginning antlers holst to
come and film the impossible they'll
refer to this as the impossible or oprah
shot a shot so spectacular oprah herself
would have to cover it he initially
declines their offer but after the
events at the star lasso experience he
changes his mind antler's name may be a
nod to an iconic scene in get out i
won't spoil it the star lasso experience
refers to jup's new show at jupiter's
claim he says that he and his family
have been feeding this monster at the
same time every week and now he's turned
it into a show and plans to exploit it
as part of his theme park he even has
tons of alien merch this exploitation
ends up biting him in the ass and it
seems this monster can't be tamed all
the spectators including this disfigured
woman who is jupe's child co-star on
gordy's home are sucked into the
monster's hole i hope i never have to
say that again now i wasn't sure because
it's never brought up in the movie if
this disfigurement was the result of
gordy's attack those years ago otis
shows up at jupiter's claim to find the
place is completely deserted that is
except for his horse lucky who is pretty
lucky to be the only survivor aside from
a pig found on a roof oj witnesses the
monster and hears the screams of the
people it is sucked inside before it
swoops in to attack him but he's knocked
out upon gaining consciousness he rushes
back to the farm but his car stops as
the ufo's electrical field nullifies it
atop his home the ufo spits out pretty
much anything that isn't organic
including coins and pieces of metal and
it does so with tremendous force that's
where that coin came from that killed
oj's father it was spit out by the
monster blood rains down on the home
from the bodies of its sucked up victims
and it's one of the film's most chilling
moments oj emerald angel and antlers
team up in another attempt to capture
the monster on camera oj refers to the
ufo as an animal and every animal has
rules to how they operate if they can
figure this ones out maybe they can
capture it on film oj believes this one
won't eat you as long as you don't look
at it perhaps a result of him being
knocked out and unable to look at it
while at jupiter's claim he ended up
surviving that antlers brings with him a
manually cranked camera bypassing the
need for electricity their plan is
pretty ingenious and involves dozens of
spaced out skydancers running on
batteries which act as detectors if one
of them stops working it means the ufo
is nearby and this thing can mimic
clouds so it can be hard to spot when
not showing itself the monster arrives
just as this tmz reporter guy comes
investigating this all goes back to
spectacle and what outlet relies on that
more than anything well tmz this guy's
electric motorcycle stops suddenly as
the creature's anti-electric field hits
it propelling him forward and gravely
injuring him now oj tries to save him
but the man is so obsessed with getting
the shot that oj has to leave him he's
sucked up and oj gallops away on lucky
as the ufo pursues but oj has a trick up
his sleeve he unfurls a large rainbow
parachute the same color as the flags
attached to the decoy horse which the
monster hated and spat out his theory
being that the monster would avoid
eating anything rainbow i know where i'm
going if one of these attacks antlers
goes for the impossible shot taking his
mobile camera and recording actually
being sucked up by the beast talk about
sacrificing yourself for your art this
is a guy who went from doing shitty
commercials that no one will ever
remember to recording one of the most
memorable things caught on film that is
if his film survives we never find out
what happened to it but we know the
monster spits out anything that isn't
organic when angel survives being sucked
up by it having wrapped himself around a
tarp and barbed wire you can make out a
broken viewfinder on the ground we
aren't sure if this is from another
camera or something that the monster
spat out but it leaves hope there is
some amazing footage out there and that
antler's sacrifice wasn't in vain the
final showdown takes place between oj
and the monster with it changing forms
from its saucer-like shape and unfurling
into this almost octopus-like entity
it's honestly one of the most strange
and alien-like things i've seen oj keeps
it busy and does this eye motion you can
see here towards emerald which is the
same thing he did when she was 9 years
old and was supposed to train jean
jacket this gives emerald enough time to
grab the electric motorbike and escape
but we aren't quite sure what happens to
oj more on that in a bit emerald makes
her way to jupiter's claim where she
untethers a giant jupe balloon hoping
that the monster will take the bait as
it floats in the air emerald takes
photographs of it using the jupiter's
claim wishing well which is this
old-fashioned tourist gimmick where
guests can have their photos taken
looking down a well however in this case
since it points right up into the sky it
allows for some great pictures of the
monster devouring the balloon once
devoured the balloon explodes blowing
the monster up with it and as the photos
develop we see that emerald got that
impossible shot a truly verifiable photo
of this ufo as emerald relishes in her
victory she sees oj in the distance on
his horse he doesn't wave or talk in
fact he and the horse don't even move
above him is a big sign from the park
that says out yonder like he's really
out somewhere else is oj dead and this
is just a figment of her imagination or
is he alive it's really up to the
audience to decide however i think it
makes more sense narratively that he's
gone much of emerald's character arc is
learning to grow up and handle things
without the help of her father or
brother she accomplishes this in the end
and oj being gone solidifies her doing
this on her own she is finely tamed jean
jacket but what did you think of nope
and its ambiguous ending is oj alive or
dead i want to hear your thoughts and
theories in the comments below thanks
for watching everyone be sure to like
and subscribe and for more bad takes you
can follow me on twitter and instagram
at think story yt until next time
remember i would have voted for obama
for a third term if i could